allora ragazzi vi ricordate four nights
anch'io è uscito un gioco che in questi
giorni sta dando un po di kakà a fort
mette non so il perché i batteri royale
siano ancora così giocati averlo provato
ho vinto grazie a me mica grazie ai miei
compagni qui lascio gameplay molto
carino magari lo riporto visto che ci
sto giocando ogni giorno praticamente
quindi la visione draga dobbiamo
vincerne dobbiamo vincerne una fidate
ora dobbiamo vincere se mentalmente tu
credi di potercela fare ce la fai
no ma tu guarda che il nostro e celtic
tu fai finta di essere dio di essere
ninja e credimi che funziona se tu non è
che devi provare adesso lo tullo 6a dove
state sparando esattamente la signora
che non vedo nessuno giuro eccolo eccolo
colpito colpiti quanto toglie star ma
andiamo coglie tantissimo io ragazzi
vado avanti con lo scudo spetta andiamo
andiamo andiamo le bombe a quelle lion o
no io no pompa questo problema
vi faccio la bua eccoli eccoli li vedete
meglio andiamo andiamo 1 dovrei averlo
buttato giù mi sai non so se ha detto
nakagami jap in alto in alternato le ha
proprio la festa quella lì di fronte
vendite mascalaito la scala gianpi punto
shuriken una dato ok bellissima siamo
sopra senso valutate occhio che qua
siamo in una
io sono curato ok perfetto anche vede
gente però amico c'è un tempo di me
gesù ci vuole malissimo
che brutta faccenda sto gioco ok un
sacco fratello mio però comunque abbiamo
intonati infatti si stanno entrando
ragazzi stanno bene 9 da che parte da
che parte definisce appunto conosciuto
ricade v.clone eccoli ancora usciamo
dall altra parte dal centro ne usciamo
veloci veloci veloci veloci lasci la cv
lasci nella ci lasci nascono diventa
ragazzi info info di curarmi curarmi non
mi hanno visto non li vedo ragazzi non
li vedono continuano vederli
eccoli esso livello di copertura un
ragazzino è joona giu l'altro giu
ragazzi ragazze manca un anima anche uno
vi sta sparando mi sta sparando vista
sparando un occhio non marina marina
morire che sarà pieno gli avrà arrestati
arriva prima dei marinesi
h lasciata la mamma mia con g7
paura gianna la che vorrei curarmi
anch'io abbiamo fatto un sacco di chi
sta arrivando la sahif ragazzi non
vorrei dirlo dobbiamo muoverci ragazzi
siamo rimasti ragazzi tre squadre
rimaste siamo in top 3 top 3 dai dai dai
dai dai colpo al me leggiuno colpo è
vero raga tre squadre rimasto uno solo
praia mi sto sforzando ragazze giochiamo
come abbiamo giocato adesso però
dobbiamo farci prendere
tu sei i ninja diciamo tu sei ninja ma
io non sono ninja aspettano fai tanto
stanno facendo
ok non c'e nessuno può non so ma stando
ai tanto sai che consentono i ragazzini
dubbi sono lì ragazzi madame da spezzano
lì sì che sono fermati ecco che tutto
aia non ha mercato
porca vacca questa nostra tranquillo
funzionari ma
ming hanno scioccato in un nanosecondo
c'è ancora qualcuno quando mi hai tirato
subito spenta però non posso
chissà chi c'era in finale di là cioè
con tutto il rispetto
ragazzi ma i toni ciao
la seduta è questa energia ma sentite
non lo so io non vedo lo spam e non vedo
lo spalleggia bonga mamma mia quanti che
che livello sei hai fatto 171 quale il
tetto record dic il 23 kg una parità
credo sia il record italiano
anche io ho fatto certo è record
italiano di killah in una partita non
c'è un sito ultra per tale via di una
volta purtroppo sono arrivato a 21 ma
niente di più vicinissimo piero fatti 22
non saprai di due fatto però forse si sa
è che nelle partite precedenti ne ho
fatti due poi hanno fatto il 32 capito
in un'altra partita
ragioniamo su questa cosa se tu sogni
tutte le killer non sia arrivato al 23
ma va o un peacekeeper a proprio così
spiattella in faccia quello che la skin
di fuoco ma che diventi se glielo troppi
tirargli dalla tua skin
si no vabbè ma da che hanno pensato a
qualsiasi cosa dai ragazzi sta partita
si vince
basta io sono carico tumore pro
[Musica]
sono nato carico un esplode ciao ciao
grazie mille grazie ragazzi per la vera
mente un bacio mi sono baciati ciafani
credo che tu sia pure io ragazzi mi
voglio bene quella giocata e ti dedico
questa vittoria perché giampiero nomi
chiudesse la porta in faccia porto il
demonio dove era il mio gruppo ho preso
a male poi segnalare figo ma voi avete
l'armor viola c'è poi noi mai neanche
nei che culo già bene ragazzi sono siamo
messi come armature se ha messi bene la
partita
questa parità dalla regia mi dicono che
potrebbe promettere molto bene e noi e
by si parte mancherebbe la strozzatura
dello shot gun e potrei quasi chiamare
che la strozzatura quella lì anche a me
manca sì sì sì a me manca ma l'avrete
notato lo shot gun a un'inter così
bellissimo no quella incredibile lascia
tirare un burke che gli fa in pratica di
ricarica il colpo scarica proprio lo
shock energia e fa più danno e la
vittoria è un po ancora un passo più
vicina a sentite io sì sento io non me
la sento ragazzi la sento proprio
vittoria
mamma mia peggio
hai ragione bravo non so più sarai tu si
certo è colpa mia in qualche modo lo so
e allora allora ragazze di chiamarla
questa l'abbiamo vista ragazzi la
chiamata lui se la chiamata io ragazzi
al segnalino dalla navicella hanno
rianimato il compagno quindi probabile
che passano di qua arrivi team quindi
venite al secondo siamo fuori se però
devo dire loro da accetto che
ragionamenti ti sei fatto vedo una smoke
stanno sparando due team segnalino due
squadre si sparano cosa facciamo li
prendiamo da sopra facciamo giro ma che
dico sempre tranquilla
e non ci troviamo in collegati all ora
c'è la 6 e usa il 3 lo re sì se non
armatura con la dietro 17 vogliamo
attaccare vi lascio un telecomando
chiudiamo a tenaglia si veniva
contestualmente qua sono da me
fondamento eccolo qua il rumor arriva
l'oro e sono date tra tre secoli una dai
dai
dopo di che potevo fare alle radici di
vita che ha rubato
diciamo no proprio no prova anche a
tutti dentro casa che cela un bouquet
cosa è successo
era la multi della banda sono qua
davanti è bravo tirati e uno dietro la
città dice vado ad attaccarlo certo non
ci vado
da qua dietro mandato forse
ok ne davano uno da una dove l'altro tra
l'altro è morta la squadra siamo
all'ultima squadra mi ha vinto dai
andiamo dai occhio non fate cagate alla
fine vi prego anzi resta ora da questa
scoppiata di fa vi è la sportiva più
grande che potessi fare questo momento e
dai avete al partito e dice che abbia
vinto non so cosa dire eccoci dente la
vedo dove si si si
vorrei vedere il finale 1 vital ciampi
arte di fase ii che li facciamo un bel
uno per la vittoria giardi earth ha una
capienza capisca rimane anch'io da che
vinta
non so dove sia non lo vedo neanche a 1
si sta curando dietro
bellissima e ci sono andati a casa se la
samp ora da casa alla fine ragazzi che
sarà apex legend apertura i jeans che vi
sia piaciuto sonorità di vista personale
gen e fatemi sapere cosa c'entra ghazi
delle prigioni come ti piace se non ci
siete
e come sempre non ci vediamo allora da
ragazzi
[Musica]